is no matter what's going on you can
choose to think differently believe
differently see differently all of those
things are a choice here's the problem I
find most people have they judge
themselves to the lens of a moment the
one thing I will say is I was grandly
ambitious I always said I'm gonna be
rich I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that
always always since the time I was a
little kid but I didn't have the drive
to see it through need motivation watch
a top 10 would believe nation
[Music]
he's Tom bill you and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success volume 9
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one focus on the adventure as Ralph
Waldo Emerson said we're all inventors
each sailing out on a voyage of
discovery guided each by a private chart
of which there is no duplicate we're all
lost at sea we're all on this grand
adventure
but the punchline is we have no idea
where we're going and the map that we
have is private only to us and it's
quite frankly blank and it's about
filling it in it's about learning where
you are it's about finding guideposts
and beginning to build this map only
from that which you've done and so you
have to go blindly forward and the only
thing that's going to give you the
courage to step into that abyss to step
into the truly unknown into the
dangerous world before you truly into a
sea of infinite peril the only thing
that's going to give you the courage to
do that is that you can learn that
you'll figure it out it's not going to
be easy it's going to be hard and at
times it is truly going to be
life-threatening but that is the nature
of life
and as you're out there in the
wilderness as you're out there lost at
sea all you have to do is remember two
things it is an adventure and adventures
are never safe but the rewards of an
adventure or the discovery of something
entirely new and two you can do it you
can do it the very fact that you're a
human gives you the ability to process
your surroundings to figure things out
to go in and fumble around you're not
going to look good you're going to drink
a ton of ocean water and it is going to
suck and you're gonna be vomiting over
the sides and it is going to be
difficult there are going to be times
when you're convinced you're going to
drown but if in those moments you stay
clear-headed and you focus on getting
better you focus on the adventure you
don't worry about the outcome you just
focus on right now in this moment with
everything going wrong what can I learn
to calm yourself and to remember right
there if you're panicking you're asking
the wrong question if you're panicking
you're asking questions about how you
look you're asking questions about how
this is going to end up
if you want to kill your panic in any
moment ask yourself right then and there
what can I learn what can I learn from
this life is nothing to practice and as
long as you keep that in mind as long as
you understand it's never performance
it's always practice it's simply an
opportunity to learn and get better then
you can reframe the entire ordeal that
you're going through and as Paulo Coelho
said people are capable at any time in
their lives of doing what they dream of
but it's only going to come true
through that process of learning and
discovery and putting yourself out there
and going into the unknown but if you're
never willing to step off because all
you can see are the problems all you can
see are the things that could go wrong
and you never get the chance to learn
but the way that you must learn is true
engagement is through interacting and if
you don't dare to do that if you don't
dare to step out into the unknown and to
flounder around and look stupid and
embarrass yourself then you're never
gonna grow and if you never grow then
never going to make your dreams come
true so if you have that dream locked
inside of you know that the only way to
get it out is to risk to dare to strive
to try to grow to grow to fall to fail
[Music]
to learn and ultimately succeed that's
the only way that dreams come true
rule number two surround yourself with
success so then these two successful
entrepreneurs walk into my class and up
to that point I promised myself two
things so I grew up chubby and a
morbidly obese family and with no money
and I said one day I'm gonna be rich and
one day I'm gonna have six-pack ABS hmm
and that was my promise and these guys
walked in and they were rich and they
had six pack abs and they said look
we're starting a technology company why
don't you come be a copywriter and I was
like absolutely and it's one of those
where people like what are you doing
like you're leaving the secure job for
me I was like they're like unicorns to
me yeah they are literally the thing I'm
looking for yeah they are rich and they
have six-pack ABS they're gonna let me
into their company yeah and so their
whole pitch was look man this is a
startup you're gonna have any job in
this company you want you just have to
become the right person for the job
so it was a tech company it was in this
beautiful office overlooking the Pacific
Ocean every single person in that
company had a floor-to-ceiling window
overlooking the Pacific Ocean except me
and they put me in the server room which
had no windows and a bunch of computers
all whirring and making noise and
remember one of the guys was like who's
the kid in the server room and so that's
how I became known I was the kid in the
server room I know anything about
business I would bring my wife she's to
visit me in the office and I'm like look
how beautiful the offices and this is
where I'm at you know literally like
those makeshift deaths that are like
really like a table that you would use
on a picnic you've got a computer
stacked on it that's where I worked all
day do you believe big time that
identity shaped by these associations in
everybody's life 100% talk about that
for size so it's so aggressive and it's
now getting repeated so I fear trite
words but words become trite because
they're so true that people repeat them
until they lose their meaning
so you're the average of the five people
you spend the most time with that's just
true and but now it's become so common
to say and it's like every Instagram
post that you know I fear it's gonna
lose its meaning who are you spending
time with because if you're spending
time with people like you you're
spending time with people like me I'm
raising you up I'm just not gonna spend
time with you so it's like now if you
get in a mix of people like that who are
like
man we'd love for you to raise up to
this level but if you don't it's fine
but we're just not gonna spend time with
you all of a sudden that desire to
belong to something powerful that you
can see is gonna lead you to your dreams
and I remember saying to my wife over
and over and over
they are the surest path to my success I
don't know anything else
I just know if I can hang on to these
guys they're gonna make me better rule
number three don't have a victims
mentality literally the first time I
wrote this whole article it was my first
blog article and it was all about how if
I were hit by a drunk driver I would
take ownership of that I would say that
is my fault and people were pissed and I
was so shocked I literally thought I
want to pull people from the matrix
what's the one gift that I could give
people that will change their life
forever and I wrote this whole thing and
I was like talking about like oh man
you're in this spot and it ends up being
a kill box and there's cars on either
side of you in a car in front of you and
your horn dies and you can't even start
your car and move you look in the
rearview mirror and this drunk drivers
plowing down they smashed into you and
it's all your fault and thank God
because now you remember that you're in
control but people thought I was victim
shaming people were outraged that I
would say that that was anyone's fault
but the drunk driver but I don't want to
do that because I choose not to ever be
a victim I cannot choose whether I'm
victimized but I have the ability to say
I will never be a victim because there's
always something you can do differently
there is always something you can do
differently and once you understand that
you can always make a different choice
and get a different reaction and that's
the power in your life that's the power
that you have is no matter what's going
on you can choose to think differently
believe differently see differently all
of those things are a choice Reid man's
search for meaning by Viktor Frankl lost
his whole family to the Holocaust was in
I think five different concentration
camps and he said the thing that people
die of in a concentrate
camp is the loss of a why and Nietzsche
said if you have a why you can survive
almost any how because you can always
change how you think about something and
when you change how you think about it's
what we've been talking about all day
when you change how you think about it
you actually change the event rule
number four don't hold yourself back
here's the problem I find most people
have they judge themselves to the lens
of a moment they fail at something they
miss the honor club they don't close
that deal they thought they were going
to they embarrass themselves they flub
something and they think that defines
who they are but I'm telling you right
now you're not defined but who you are
you're defined by who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there also if you want to learn how
to have confidence like Tom and other
successful entrepreneurs check out my
250 for confidence series it's in the
description below and it's free there's
a gap between who people are and what
they tell you they want to accomplish
rule number five continue to push here's
the hard truth about getting great
[Music]
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self-worth so that you can
still get the momentum going but you
have to understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible
and as Henri cartier-bresson said your
first 10,000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day
overtime going out every day on the
parade of whether or not this is one of
the 10,000 terrible things that you're
gonna do it's being unafraid to make
those mistakes as being unafraid that
you're not yet great and as Marianne rad
maker says
courage doesn't always war sometimes
courage is the quiet voice at the end of
the day saying I will try again tomorrow
and that's it if you want to be great
that's what you have to do you've got to
get up again tomorrow you've got to be
willing to face another day you've got
to be willing to accept that you've got
to get through the bad ideas before you
can get to the good you've got to
understand that you have to start as an
apprentice you have to start as a person
going and getting tea and you have to
accept that that's the job that you
should be playing that you should be
working for somebody else you should be
looking up to somebody else's seeing
what they can teach you because what you
know is that you're there to learn
that you're there to get through the
10,000 bad photographs you need to get
through to ultimately achieve greatness
and if you make the catastrophic error
that's so many may to try to tell them
whether you're extraordinary today
to try to get the world to follow you
and look up to you and Faithie or
something today
[Applause]
because the people that never win
the ones that you listen to
the ones who spend every ounce of their
energy amassing mastery getting better
every day working their asses off to
improve their skill set to relentlessly
look at the things that they're not
doing well to understand that they have
to break themselves down and get rid of
all of their ego before they can really
find greatness those are the people that
we remember so if you want to be
remembered if you want to achieve real
greatness you just need to have the
courage to show up every day and take
another swing take another photo try
another task do something that scares
you and do those little things over and
over and over until you win rule number
six don't be an empty dreamer the one
thing I will say is I was grandly
ambitious
I always said I'm gonna be rich I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that
always always since the time I was a
little kid but I didn't have the drive
to see it through so I really really was
an empty dreamer when I was a kid and it
was learning to hate that in myself if
I'm completely honest and to not allow
myself to be an empty dreamer to force
myself to get the skills to actually
execute against it to not be in any way
shape or form pacified by saying I'm
gonna do something which is actually
super dangerous
most people just thinking about the
fantasy of what they're gonna do
gives them some partial sense of oh I've
done it mmm whereas I stopped letting
that be okay for me which largely came
down to embarrassment I felt around my
wife working when I had no job and that
was the time she was my fiancee at the
time yeah but that was when I really
started to go okay you've made a lot of
promises to this woman and you're not on
a path to keep any of them rule number
seven take responsibility Tom am I going
to make it do I have what it takes when
you look into my future can you see me
making it and I'm gonna cut to the chase
for all of you and your mistake what I'm
about to say for good news and then I'm
gonna tell you why it's actually
worst thing I could tell you you all
meet minimum requirements you all meet
minimum requirements so whatever it is
you want to do I'm not gonna say that
it's gonna be easy for you because
you're ultra smart or something you
probably aren't but everyone that I've
encountered here literally without
exception every single person that has
come up to me and said something you
meet minimum requirements even you
awkward they have a hard time like
making eye contact even you guys I'm
telling you right now you've got
something you're gonna have to deal with
but you meet minimum requirements
now minimum requirements for what for
whatever you want
now that sounds great right oh [ __ ]
Tom said I can make it this is amazing
but all I've actually said is now if you
don't make it it's on you
and that's it there's nobody else to
blame everything is your fault
everything rule number eight change your
mindset once you understand the whole
reason to acquire a skill is that it
gives you power
now I'm gonna define power power to me
is the ability to close your eyes and
imagine a world the world the way you
wish it was and then open your eyes and
make that world come true that's power
and the thing that stands between you
where you are today and your goals where
you want to get is a gap in skill set it
is a gap in abilities and once you're
willing to look naked Liat your
inadequacies to literally build your
self-esteem your entire sense of
self-worth and value is built around one
thing whenever you face an obstacle
whenever you face a difficulty whenever
you fail you have one thing that you say
to yourself on a long enough timeline I
can learn this when you switch your life
around to that whatever your goal is
here whatever part of the honors Club or
the leading edge you're at or if you
want to go beyond that
whatever that is wherever you want to go
plant that flag identify the skills that
you would need to get there and then set
about every day getting those skills
rule number nine empower yourself people
get the do part they understand their
action should be actions that take them
towards what they want to accomplish but
people often miss the most important
part which is only to believe things
that move you towards your goals and I
see people every day that tell
themselves the story about themselves
that they are worthless that they're
meaningless that they're pointless that
their friends and family would be better
off if they just died so we have to find
a way to construct a narrative about
ourselves that empowers us that lifts us
up even though even though we make
mistakes even though we fall down even
though we're never going to get things
right all the time and even though
terrible things happen to us or maybe we
do terrible things but in that the
erosion of the self that's the danger
the erosion of the self that is the
danger and when I talk to people about
the 80/20 principle 80% of the time you
should be focused on the things that you
love the beautiful things do you want to
bring to this world the beautiful things
that are already in the world and 20% of
the time you should be kicking yourself
in your ass and saying you can do better
it's such a powerful idea but the
problem is when people get to the 20%
they forget that it's only supposed to
be 20% of the time and that it's meant
to be these acute
that's where you're pushing yourself to
be more to do more it isn't so you can
tear yourself down that's why you have
to do and believe that which moves you
towards your goals and if thinking that
you're a worthless piece of [ __ ] moves
you to your goals somehow then fine do
it but I can't literally fathom a
universe in which that would be a
logical way to move forward so I'm gonna
give you the magic words that you need
right now to never fall prey to that
believing I'm worthless does not serve
me and I don't do things that don't
serve me repeat that in your head every
time you begin to disparage yourself and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is wanted badly
enough here's the harsh reality you're
just not good enough yet as Brian Tracy
said your true success in life begins
only when you make the commitment to
become excellent at what you do this is
the gap that I see in most people's
lives did not yet made the commitment to
become extraordinary and the reason that
they haven't made that commitment yet is
they don't believe that they can they're
afraid of what it might take to get
there they just don't want it enough
that's the reality most people don't
want it enough to face all of that they
don't want to face their inadequacies
they don't want to accept that they're
gonna have to go through that process
that gut wrenching back-breaking process
of becoming great and every day lulls
them into this sense that there's always
time to do it tomorrow but the reality
is there is only now there is only today
and if you really want to do something
with your life that leaves your own jaw
on the floor that leaves you
in awe of what you've done you're going
to have to admit you're not yet good
enough you've got to put in that work
that you've got to develop a set of
skills that simply can't be denied but
if you do that on the other side of
getting that good and falling in love
with something and working so hard that
you can feel yourself changing as a
human being on the other side of that is
something unimaginably beautiful and as
Les Brown said if you set goals and go
after them with all the determination
you can muster your gifts will take you
places that will amaze you that's what I
want in my life and I hope that's what
you want in yours is to be amazed to be
amazed at how extraordinary this life
really is this opportunity to make of
yourself anything you want to be really
think about that for a second you can
become anything you want to become you
can become an astronaut a world-class
athlete a musician the best parent that
this world has ever seen anything you
want is yours for the taking
but it takes effort it takes a
willingness to stare naked Liat your
inadequacies it takes a willingness to
really gut check yourself about where
you are today and it doesn't mean that
you can't go and be something better
tomorrow and falling in love with that
process that knowing - being a human and
really getting the most out of your
potential is not to know that tomorrow I
can be better than I am today and that
doesn't make you a bad person today
it's okay to know that you can be better
tomorrow and still love yourself today
but it's also okay to love yourself
today and demand that you get better
tomorrow and once you can do that there
is literally nowhere you can't go now
I've got a special bonus clip from Tom
and how to focus on the light that I
really think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
what will you do to empower yourself
right now number two what's the mindset
change that you need to make and number
three what do you need to start taking
more responsibility for find a place
inside where there's joy and the joy
will burn out the pain now I get it
life inevitably comes with some degree
of misery and I get it for many of you
things have happened in your past that
are unspeakable and whether that's
something big or whether it's something
small each one of us has something
inside of us that hurts it's something
that we wish weren't so it's something
that we focus on when we're alone it's
the thing that keeps us up at night it's
a thing that wakes us up in the morning
it's the thing that we obsessively come
back to over and over and over for
whatever reason that we think means that
we're not good enough but I also know
that inside each one of us is something
beautiful that even in the midst of pain
if you allow yourself to focus on that
to feel the joy to not just think about
it but to actually feel the joy it will
begin to crowd out the pain it will
actually take that room and just like
when you're trying to create something
amazing in your life do not waste
trying to tear down the old if you're
trying to create something beautiful in
your life spend all of your time trying
to build that new thing so if you want
to feel joy
don't try to eradicate the pain instead
focus all of your energy on that joy and
let it become so bright that it
ultimately takes over the pain and as
aristotle said it is during our darkest
moments that we must focus to see light
and that's the thing with pleasure and
pain when you've got that ache inside of
you when you feel that something in your
past is stopping you from moving forward
it is in that moment that you must put
your focus and attention on the things
that are good on the things you've done
that are good on the joys and the beauty
and the things in your life that you're
grateful for all of that if you take
your time and you put your focus on that
even when it hurts especially when it
hurts if you're able to do that if
you're able to find a way to take all of
your energy and put it on that to repeat
it to let it become a mantra to let it
be the first thing you think about when
you wake up the last thing you think
about in the night and the thing that
you cling to when you wake up and cannot
fall asleep if you let it be that thing
that you can put all of your attention
on that then you can actually change
your chemistry you can actually change
your own story you can actually change
your life
but you've got to know it's in our
darkest moments that we must focus on
the light
if you want more time bill you check
that the top 50 rules video made on him
as well the link is right there next to
me I'll see you there is something that
you have no natural inclinations forward
then go learn that go get extraordinary
go become the best of whatever it is you
want to be but go become the best of it